do you get starstruck when you meet
Michael I do sometimes I do sometimes I
remember when I was young I and I met
Laurence Olivier well that was I used to
collect autographs at the stage door and
he came out and I remember so distinctly
that I started to cream in my knickers
[Laughter]
I honestly don't think I've ever been
more uncomfortable
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I think that's the worst moment of my
life
are you talking about those mysterious
hair loss for women
you mean the balding pudenda that's
right the balding pudenda Zenda yeah got
you what is that Wow in ones you always
do I want to know what this but I will
just put it there was once a time where
I can't believe you don't know yeah can
you say forget I can say it again
pubic see you're not a doctor but we'll
still let
once where there was an afro right that
I can put beads on and brave
yeah there is now Paul Shaffers okay
okay empty balls there we go
but there's more to it but you have to
come yeah Cameron has also been in the
papers recently very strongly that all
woman should maintain some pubic hair
Cameron feels very strongly about this
maintain take it out every now and then
comb it in terms of my comfort zone I'm
far away from it that is an
inappropriate metaphor
[Applause]
we're talking okay can I just clear
something up really - if you live okay
yeah did you ever ask you a question
like why are you there why are you there
why
[Laughter]
I wanna have a direct community
[Applause]
slightly loud voice my good
did your school sing
you were very hungover oh yeah tell Tony
Foster that story Oh less stories are
really cool oh great when I was teaching
this is what this show is based on I I
went home one weekend and I was in my
30s I was probably 33 years of age I
went home to see my mother and then I
went back and while I was at home my
mother did my washing for me because I
was only 33 back on the on the Sunday
night I got really drunk and then I went
for a curry and then the next day I went
into school I'm gonna I went into school
and it was a school in Slough and it was
quite a rough school but I had a really
brilliant hearing-impaired Department so
they were hearing impaired kids who you
know struggled they were they were
really looked after in the school anyway
I was really hung over I went there and
I bet break time I felt really
uncomfortable I thought something's not
right you know so I went to the toilet
and I pulled my trousers down and some
of my mother's knickers have got I've
got mixed up in the Washington and I was
wearing my mother's
and I went oh god now I remember going
are you loser this is such a low point
you [ __ ] loser
and then the Korean food the curry and
the booze kicked in from the night
before so I I I did like a fecal Jackson
Pollock
that's like Oh God not this as well oh
Jesus so I clean myself up I pulled my
mother's pants back went back into the
classroom and I saw one of the hearing
impaired kids looking at me like this
and that's what I remembered that my I
had a microphone directly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
weird and don't answer this question if
you don't want your mother but I have I
don't know why you brought this up but I
did hear you discuss you had an
extraordinary disagreement with your
wife about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about by myself you mean yes
with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff and of course being
circumcised I said she said she said
you're not circumcised I said what do
you mean you've only known me a few all
my life I remember my mother telling me
why because it was fashionable at the
time she said you're not circumcised I
said that's ridiculous
I should know if I'm sorry conversation
but the next day I happened to be seeing
my doctor I was seeing my doctor for my
annual physical of course
so what he was down there
oh by the way disagreement I am
circumcised all right because she says
I'm not and he goes so he looked down
again and he said hey I'm Jewish I know
the difference
[Laughter]
[Music]